AND CA IT TO THE LINE.
AND HERE IS JOHANSSON TAKES THEA
GLANCE AT THE GAME, AS SENDS IT
BEHIND THE SHOT. SEASONS IN SMA.
JOHANSSON
KUNNIN.NED THAT MILESTONE.
HERE IS JOSI AND THERE IS A SHOT
THERE IS SAROS FIGHTING THAT NI.
>> A SHOT, SAVED AROUND THE BOAY
FROM THE
WAY THROUGH TO SAROS.
MCCANN TAKES IT DOWN
OPENS UP SO MCCANN THE
NEAR SIDE AND SEND IT UP
AGAINST THE OVE UP 1-0.
THEY WERE LOOKING TO ADD. AND SN
TAKES THE TOP, OVER FROM THING N
IS DOING.
>> Leah:
THAT IS ABSOLUTETE GOT THE SAVED
FAR SIDID HIM.
JEANNOT DROPS IT OFF.
HERE IS MENTIONED
DOWN B BEEING IS
THE RESULT OF IT.
>> Leah: 20 POINTS TO PLAY. IS
BLACKWELL.
HE HAS SOME SPACE.
TAKE RIGHT SHOT AND THEY
SCORE.
MATT DUCHENE WITH A POWER PLAY
L
TIP FROM FORSBERG THAT LOW.
HERE IS